hello welcome to this video playing hi
pooja let's check singapore i suspected
something like that but i couldn't
really tell the flag do we have a name
here um enrique r % yeah okay UNT sexy
IM going from some old Indian type set
up an interesting point is that i think
ii four is better than d for SD for
allows like to play your form this is
prevented here so we have a few cattle
set up with white against the old Indian
this is not the most dangerous way of
handling this opening what will seem
interesting we're here see five comes
into consideration c5 doesn't really
convince all that much
yeah I'm just centralizing see what he
comes up with okay it was a five it's a
bit of a surprise usually they try a 6b
five in those positions so I'm going to
go to 55 he doesn't have a 92 c5
currently okay you can lose more time
and yes going back that's certainly
possible so if I go 83 will go 95
potentially a form but it doesn't really
work all that well let's see night 2 we
had 93 maybe which is irritating maybe
it isn't yeah it wasn't all that great
but nitra d3 is not bad not bad anyway
because the night is very often good on
d3 in these kind of situations for
example here if he goes yeah this is an
interesting move he is giving up a pawn
and I will take it but he wanted he
prevents before like that here the night
also in these kind of situations it's
not bad on you one as d3 is quite a
decent square for it okay um 93
immediately it's possible let's let's go
for it se5 is hanging this is an
interesting an interesting moment i
wonder if i can take c6c arrows or if
this is a bad idea if i take them
there's potentially know pretty six i
can take on b6 that doesn't work okay
then i can take
yeah here I'll get a night to d5 and
yeah but you five to ten here 95
95 we can move the queen to d6 or
something to do six OKs and then just
this one funky place you for the rukon
deform not clear to me if this is a
well-positioned piece or not can be both
yeah but now I can take you five and
there is really no reason not to do it
or once this what's the deal Queen to
you six and I just go back what's the
point okay
currently I'm threatening a 5 which is
duly ignored yeah well maybe you can
ignore it c4 is hanging okay I'm
covering this and I can do this in a
technical way like a four I'm just two
bonds up what C 2 SC CH 14 night f4 okay
if I go here you might have Queen to you
five you five immediately does win
material some material but you have to I
have really only have time here there's
no need to rush things now we'll just
night a4 and take on d forces
technically very clean i think if you
take speed the pawn of a 93 and just
pick up the pawn because you cannot they
cannot support this in any way queen bee
too
check Jim this doesn't work Alaric
resigns Jim and I think MP probably I
don't know about this pawn sec that
might be possible I'm not totally ruling
it out but I have my doubts that he has
enough for the pawn um yeah thing is a
little bit if he does not play a form
this whole an opening wasn't a success
so what is he supposed to play let's say
a normal-looking move Bishop d7 I go
before me and like this this this and
then 93 this is not a particularly good
position and white has far more space
and what are all those pieces doing him
it's not not particularly attractive
yeah if force is an interesting move he
gives up this pawn and yeah gets the
bishops but it's difficult for the
bishops to do much this is the problem
here sometimes you can sacrifice a pawn
like that in the Kings Indian where the
dark squared Bishop is getting into
action by age six for example but this
is not going to happen here right here
here and yeah now I think after b6 the
position becomes very favorable the
engine wants to take him which does make
some sense i try to open up the position
if i do this c4 is an interesting move a
bit i have to be three here right yeah
cam winning this poem hmm ok so here I
took it oh I've landed rook takes 23 oh
that's awful
oh my god so I should have played here
right to to do basic to the same thing
take later ah that's bad I really looked
I really overlooked dad yeah this is
nice no for black he will win this porn
and he has his minor pieces now are very
strong after we should be six later he
would have total control over all those
squares and then he only has to move
maneuver the night to d4 and I'm enough
and I'm a woman and I'm done oh it was a
bad mistake and now everything is cool
again this position is extremely
comfortable snatch the second horn and
here it's basically metal a good
technique white also has time him not
some time check and give me give me the
rook wit it really didn't matter anymore
this was a fairly clean on clear win
however the bad mistake that rook takes
2-3 that would have been very awful okay
thanks for watching